So, my name is Kelly Chen. I consider myself a Bay
Area native. I grew up in Fremont, and I'm a Genetic
Counselor. And technically, I guess my title is Perinatal Genetic Counselor.
So I focus on patients who are pregnant or thinking about pregnancy.
>> And as a Genetic Counselor, are there sub disciplines like, I mean are
there Genetic Counselors who focus on sort
of the non perinatal aspect? Certainly, so this
profession is still pretty new. I think in
the beginning, there weren't that many specialties. It was
either pediatrics children, and, and prenatal was the second
I think, as, as soon as pregnancy tests started.
And since then, there are several specialties. The big
ones are pediatrics, prenatal, cancer has become the hot
new thing. counselors who work in a laboratory. And
then specialty counselors, who work in certain disciplines like
cardiology, or neurology, or.
>> I see. And what are the, what are the various backgrounds? Do all
genetic counselors have the same academic training?
Or, or, do they have diverse academic training?
>> So, yeah. So, counselors come from a wide variety
of backgrounds. they do have in common that they have
to have a masters degree. And the Masters degree programs
require an undergraduate, usually 4 year college. But, and some prerequisite
science courses, biology, chemistry. but other than that you can
be any major. So, my classmate was a psychology major.
I was a genetics major. some people were completely not
really into either specialty as long as they finish their courses.
>> And did you always know you wanted to be
a genetic counselor, or was this a later decision or?
>> So, it's very interesting. I'll tell you this story, and I like
to share it when I give talks, that I didn't find out about
genetic counseling until about a year after I graduated
from undergrad. I went to UC Berkeley, and I knew
I liked science, and I really liked genetics. So
I was a genetics major. And at that time, when
I was going to school, the main option was
to be like a physician. And there wasn't many other
allied health care positions. And so, when I found out
that that wasn't really what was my career path I
decided to go into something totally different for a couple of
years. it was only after I was really, after I had graduated,
unpacked my boxes from college, that I picked up a brochure
about genetic counseling. And that's how I found out about the profession.
>> Wow.
>> I just find it ironic just because UC Berkeley
had one of the oldest genetic counseling prog, training programs
at that point. They were probably, like in the first
four. So it had been going on for 20, 30 years.
And when I was an undergrad, I had no
exposure or or knowledge about the program. And so, now
I feel like every time I get a chance
to give back, I, I like to promote the profession.
>> Nice. What kind of training was involved, so once you figured out
that's something you wanted. what do you
do to become a genetic counselor officially?
>> So, it's very specific. So it's usually a 2 or 3 year master's
program. specifically in genetic counseling. So, all
the courses are geared towards the science
of genetics and counseling theory. And so, right now, I just did this
[UNKNOWN],
I think there are about 30 programs nationwide. So there are three in
California and in other states. And so you still have to apply, take
standard testing like GRE's, they're still
around. And do some training like volunteering
in health care settings. So I volunteered to planned parenthood for a year.
>> I see.
>> Doing the pregnancy tests.
>> Cool.
>> And then applied.
>> Are there different certifications for different
States. Like if you get trained in
one State. If you're in the United States, would do
have an international audience? But if you're in the United States,
if you get certified, or get your degree, are you
able to move and, and, and be a genetic couselor in
any State? That's a really good question. So, the certification
and, and the accreditation process for genetic counselors has changed. It
used to be a certificate issued by a national organization,
through our national organization called
National Society of Genetic Counseling. and
then, just probably in the past 5, 6 years, many of the states
pushed for licensure so that we have a license, just like any other healthcare
professional, dog groomer, hair dresser. Which
would open up opportunities for billing and
for status, and things. So, this states
just started issuing licenses 4 years ago.
>> I see. What do you think about the profession itself
overall? Is it, is it a profession that's growing in number?
and, and how is it growing, if it is?
>> So yeah, the, the profession itself definitely is
growing in number. I don't have year by year,
but I think, in the very beginning, I think
the first national society started in the late 70s. And
then there are probably 10 to 30 members maybe,
and now I think we're up to past 2,000
nationwise. in the state, I'm organizing this conference coming
up, so I just did some stats. In this state,
there's probably about 400 licensed genetic counselors. So just to give
a perspective of. We're still a small specialty, but definitely growing.
>> Is, I, I guess this so, sort of more of the
personal side, but I mean, is, do you like being a genetic
counselor? Do you feel like you're helping people? What, what aspect of
doing this job is probably the, the best and most fulfilling for you?
>> I think it's a combination of things. Like this
job definitely, I, I really enjoy being a genetic counselor.
It really fits my niche. That, it combines my
interest and my love of science, and specifically genetics
and genetic conditions, with seeing patients, helping people in
a health care setting. So, I've been thinking about some
of these answers, that you know, the traditional role
for a health care professional is a doctor. But
doctors have a lot of stress, a lot of
schooling. doing treatments and procedures. And I wasn't necessarily interested
in that part. I was really more interested in communicating to patients. And
feeling like I could help them just using my words. Or just being
there for them and listening to them. So, I really feel that this
profession has been a really good fit, for, for, for me and my personality.
>> That's great.
>> Yeah.
>> Now you said you're a perinatal genetic counselor. So walk us through,
what is like? I mean who, what kind of patient comes to you, and
how does the workflow process work when they seek out a genetic counselor?
>> So, the workflow for a perinatal
genetic counselor. And paranetal is actually kind
of a new phrase we created at where I work. Traditionally, the word has
been prenatal. So, before birth, and then
there's postnatal. And now that we're doing
so much intervention before birth that affects
after birth, we use the combination of perinatal.
So most of the patients that I
see are pregnant, actively pregnant and thinking about
doing some testing to check for either genetic
conditions or birth defects. sometimes we see patients
before they get pregnant, but they know they
want to have children and know that they might
be at risk for a certain condition. So,
our appointments are fairly, they're like office consultations.
>> Mm-hm.
>> We do a little prep-work. We might contact
them on the phone and get a little family history or medical
history. and then our meeting with them is probably about 40 minutes, 40
to 60 minutes long. and then afterwards, if we've ordered testing or there's
other appointments to make. We'll follow up and, and help patients with that.
>> I'm really curious about the, the testing. So
do patients come to you and say, I want to
know what's in my genes or what I pass on, and you guys do a test for them?
>> Yeah. So I think our patients
are a little biased. I mean, I'm sure there, it seems
like there, there are certainly patients out there who would say,
or people out there who would say they don't want to
learn, know their genetic status. And those patients we never end up
seeing, because they would just decline an appointment with us. So
those that we do see definitely are interested in some kind
of genetic information. Whether it's for themselves or primarily for their
pregnancy, or their future child. so,
yeah. So, sometimes there's something specific
in the family that we're looking for. We've had some patients just say, test
me for everything, I want to know everything.
And we have to explain the science and
technology's not quite there yet. And so we're trying to pin point, what can we
offer you? Accurate testing, specific testing, something
that will be helpful to you. So, yeah.
>> And what kind of what do you think about this sort of
new wave of personal genetics, and, and companies that are able to you
know, get samples from individuals and, and,
and look at genes for them. How does,
how does that fit in with this whole process of, of patients coming to you.
>> Right. So, this whole wave of personal genomics they've
called it. it's a, it's a separate court category by itself.
And hasn't quite crossed in the penal realm yet. But,
I mean, we certainly hear about it indirectly from our colleagues.
I think e, just with our experience with the
genetic testing, a lot of genetic testing is not straightforward.
Sometimes we find things and we don't know how to
interpret. And so, the personal genomics, I think is a,
exciting new field. But also, as with any new
test comes with limitation. And you know, those of us
in the community of genetic counselors, some are very supportive
of that technology. Some of us are still a little
hesitant and cautious about, is it more harmful
and helpful to start looking for things that
may not have a co, complete answer to,
like opening up Pandora's box kind of thing.
>> Can you give me any examples, any specific examples of traits like that
that you think are, you know, make it more difficult to really understand. Like
is there a particular kind of dilemma, or is the patient ever come to
you, or you felt you were in a situation where you were giving them information
that they couldn't do anything with anyhow?
>> Yeah, so there's, there's actually, so, I
have a few examples. So one, one example
of a test that's not straightforward, that kind
of gives us a little difficulty in counseling, is
maybe for a condition like hemochromatosis. So, that's
an adult type onset condition, where you don't have
symptoms until you reach adulthood, and it causes
iron storage or overload. It can be treated fairly
easily, but it does need treatment. the issue with
the genetics of it is that there is a
gene or two genes associated with the condition, but
the gene is not the full picture. So people
who have changes in the gene don't always have
the condition. and so I think there's a lot
of conditions like that. Alzheimer's, high cholesterol levels, where
you identify a gene but it's not 100% correlation that
that gene change always causes symptoms. And then you're left with not
the co, not the whole picture, and you're giving probabilities. And so then
the issue becomes, is that helpful to know about, know about a
possibility that you may or may not be able to change or treat?
>> Mm-hm.
>> So that's been I think the big dilemma. The ethical dilemma is, some people
would say I'd still want to know, because I want to prepare myself and try to
do as much prevention as possible.
>> Sure.
>> Other people would say, well, if it's not for sure, I'm going to be left
worrying and, and I'd rather just take it as it comes. So I think that's the big
issue with the new genetic te, technologies in
general. Whether it's looking for a trait or
a specific condition that, most of the testing
right now is not 100, 100% accurate or specific.
>> Right. It sounds like a lot of what
you end up doing as well as sort of education,
patient education of traits and testing, and how to interpret various results.
>> Definitely. So, a lot of what I do is I think of it as a
consultation, but also just providing information. I see
us as a link between physicians and patients, that
traditionally doctors order tests that are fairly straightforward
like a blood count. Or a blood type,
or something like that. And they can easily
tell a patient what that means in a sentence.
With this genetic testing, it's much more complicated than
that. it's not always a straightforward yes or no, and
doctors don't have time to spend with patients explaining that.
And so I see us as a bridge between that.
Being able to help patients decipher and interpret this information.
And then also helping them make decisions based on those
results. because a lot of decisions to be made, especially
in pregnancy, are not always medical decisions, they're personal decisions
about what patients want to do about information, about
their future offspring. so, so prenatal specifically is an
interesting ethical realm, because we're also dealing with pregnancy
and, and termination. What's the most difficult aspect of
that if I can ask. is it, is it
patients actually you know, deciding about you know, continuing
the pregnancy versus not? are there significant traits that
they have to deal with? I just, I'm looking
for some kind of idea when it, when it does
get gray as far as the difficult part of the job.
>> Yeah, so, yeah, no you bring up a good
point. I actually hadn't thought about that before. One of the
difficulties in the job, in what I do with pregnancy
is, we're not always we're, we're certainly talking about genetic testing.
>> Sure.
>> Sometimes, we're dealing with other kinds
of tests in pregnancy, like ultrasounds. So,
a video picture of the baby. Where you see a physical problem that might
be something that suggests a genetic condition like Down Syndrome, or
something else. And seeing the physical problem doesn't guarantee what the
outcomes going to be. And so that is one difficulty in
prenatal, that you don't have a live person in front of you
to say, oh, this person is actually fine. Maybe they have
an extra finger or toe, but they're otherwise healthy. In a
pregnancy, you don't, you don't have that baby in front of
you, and you can't check if there's other things going on. So
I think that definitely is one difficult aspect
of what I do specifically. and I would just
say in general, just dealing with pregnant patients
is tough. Pregnancy is a time limited event, so
I feel like of all the specialties in
genetic counseling, prenatal is usually the one the, the
most time sensitive. We're under deadlines for scheduling
appointments, seeing patients, test results. and just the anxiety
of the patients themselves. They also have the hormone issues to deal with.
>> Mm-hm.
>> It's a very emotional time. So it can
be quite challenging, but it also can be quite satisfying.
>> Sure. Actually there is an interest
[UNKNOWN]
haven't thought of either. I mean I guess and, and
it's portrayed in the media, at least maybe in TV
and movies to a certain extent. That you know, these
kinds of, this kind of information or even services for reproductive
services, I, I don't know the best way to, to
say that. for couples, it's generally considered more of a middle
to upper class sort of information thing. It's this what,
what, what is that like in the genetic counseling. What I
mean, do, is it something that only certain
couples end up doing, because you know, their
by, you know, I actually don't know the
best way to phrase this question. But you
know, is, is, is access to this sort of across the board for all types? What's
the general demographic of people who are sort
of taking part of trying to find this information?
>> Yeah. So, at least here in California, we're, in this Bay
Area, I think we're in a unique bubble in terms of who comes
to see us and access. you know, the state
government has ensured that all pregnant women have some
kind of medical coverage during the pregnancy. So, we're
fortunate that we can see patients on the state
insurance called Medi-Cal and as well as private pay
patients. I think the issue, I think many patients
who come see us are very appreciative of, of
what we can provide, but different patients need different things.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So patients
who are lower to middle class, or of lower
education status, may not need all the explanation of the
genetic testing. May be less likely to take the
genetic testing. But could still benefit for meeting with us
to explain all the options. so we see a
huge spectrum of patients. but even in my employers group,
we have different offices. So, in different cities. So
the area that I'm in is, isn't an affluent area,
private insurance patients are the ones I generally see.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Who are educated and, and know the lingo of chromosomes and, and genes.
>> versus, we have a office in the southern portion of
the Bay area where there are more non-English speaking patients, patients that
are on the state medical insurance. Who, who don't know what a
chromosome is may not be interested in further genetic testing. So, that,
yeah. Could there be a challenge, sort of dealing
with different patients at the same time too? .
>> Yeah.
>> E, e, if it were in the same you know, practice or office too.
>> Yeah, usually we,we find it helpful,
like our group specifically will call patients, at
least try to contact some patients ahead of time to see what their concerns are.
So we call that a phone intake. And we find it really helpful especially for
the higher end, more educated patients who have
a specific agenda or specific questions they want
answered to do that, do it that way.
>> So, I'm, I'm also curious. What is, is there a common
trait or condition that you counsel for the most. Like what is, what
are the things that you either end up counselling for, or do
people come to you and ask them, what are they most interested in?
>> So, for my specific specialty in prenatal. by far, I
think nationwide, the common condition that
we're talking about is Down's Syndrome.
I was thinking about how I explained why. I think it's
a combination of things. Because the condition is genetic, but it's
not inherited. so, it would randomly appear, and there would be
no other way to tell about it other than to check
for it in that pregnancy. And is, there's a known association
with the age of the mom. As women get older, there's
a higher chance of Down Syndrome. the insurances actually will cover
testing for Down Syndrome, so that's kind of a supportive step
that, that he, aids us in seeing patients.
it's common, common condition, I think about 1 in
800, 1000 births for Down syndrome occur. And it
can be a long-term disability. Children with Down syndrome
grow up into adults, they have intellectual disability,
they can have health issues. And so, it seems
like there's enough interest in that, that we have
this testing. So for my specialty, it's fairly easy,
we, we talk primarily about that and some
related conditions. whereas in other specialties like pediatrics, where
I use to work it could be a range of things. a variety of things depending on
what a child comes in to see, for us to see. Whether it's a learning problem, we
think about, would make us think about certain
conditions versus if it was a physical birth defect.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Like a heart defect or a cleft
lip that would shift our gear to something else.
>> If
you do enough testing for something like Down Syndrome, does
that mean you're taking a genetic sample from the developing embryo?
>> So, that is still the goldstar. Yes, the test for down syndrome accurately
is still an invasive test where you're
taking tissue indirectly from the baby. So,
either amniocentesis or chorionic villi sampling, which
have been, I think available for a
generation now. So, those are still kind of the gold standard way to test
for Down syndrome and other chromosome problems, because
we have tissue from that baby. but more and
more over the years, we have a lot more
alternate tests that don't require evasiveness into the pregnancy.
Primarily blood tests and ultrasounds that can check markers
for Down syndrome, versus the amnion CVS are looking
at the chromosomes and looking at the cause of
Down syndrome. So, so now we have a combination
of both, and I think especially now, patients are faced
with so many choices. It really can help them to
meet with us to sort out all the different options,
the benefits, the risks, numbers, detection rates, things like that.
>> What's the most difficult trait you've had to
counsel? Is it Down syndrome, or is there another
more difficult situation or trait that you've had to,
let us say counsel a family on or a couple?
>> So, Down syndrome is always, it's, it's always a difficult trait. Like, I
was thinking about this because I have
experience both in prenatal and in pediatrics.
I mean one of my most memorable patient cases
had to, not to do with a Prenatal case,
but a pediatric case. Where we were seeing a
child and part of the list of conditions we
were thinking about was Tay–Sachs disease. So that's one
is also a known single gene recessive condition that
is common in people of Jewish background. So when
we were thinking about that disease, that usually means
the child is coming in with delays, and maybe normal
development than loss of delays. so, it's not like it
was, it's a surprise to the family, we, we would
talk to them about this is a possibility. We're going to
be ordering tests for this condition. but it's always hard
to have to call or contact the family and tell
them this is, this is a condition. So I think
any kind of test result that confirms a condition that it
has high risk for complications or early
death. that's never easy to, to, to convey.
>> You do pedigrees, don't you?
>> Yes, we do, we always do pedigrees.
it's kind of our shorthand for gathering medical information.
>> Are you fast? Are you good? How fast can you draw a pedigree?
>> I'm pretty fast, people, my colleagues would say, I'm
too fast at a lot of things. So I'm pretty fast
at drawing a pedigree. We have colleagues that have the template that
had, they used to have a template that you could trace a pedigree.
>> Oh, my gosh.
>> And so I had colleagues who could whip
out that that template and do the, the rotation of
things. But most of us can draw free hand pretty
well. But now, there are programs that also draw pedigrees.
>> Sure.
>> because mine are fairly basic, I can
take maybe three generations of pedigrees. So patients,
their children, and then their parents. some pedigrees like for cancer, where
you're really trying to pinpoint all
the individuals with cancer, those pedigrees could
get huge. And then, I think the counselors definitely need help with
a program that can kind of line things up and sort things out.
>> So do families really have all this information?
Like are you able to build like these massive
pedigrees? Or do you end up building these sort
of, more like, just maybe two or three generation pedigree?
>> So, families vary in how much information they can
give us for pedigrees. I see a lot of patients also,
I should mention that comes from other countries. Especially, specifically
Asia, where not as, not much is known about family members.
People don't talk about conditions in the family. So the
ped, and, and people don't have that many children, so the
pedigrees can be very sparse. So just like a circle
and a square, and circle and a square, and that's it.
And then all the way to families who have their whole
genealogy trees mapped out with the aid of all these online tools.
>> Right.
>> so they come in with their pedigrees already
drawn. So, it's really a fun part of our
draw, job, but it's also efficient to draw this
out instead of trying to describe all these people.
>> Well, I have a really interesting question to ask for all of our
students who might be struggling with pedigrees
out there. How do you as an actual
genetic counselor, let's say you're studying a trait.
How do you distinguish when you're looking at
traits, a recessive or dominant trait and put
it in context of what you think's going on?
>> So the, so, trying to figure out a
trait, whether it's dominant, recessive, or X-linked, those are
the top three modes of inheritance that we're looking
at. We actually have a term called pedigree analysis
[LAUGH].
and you know, it's, it's a subjective thing, but
it really is looking at the pedigree. And going
through kind of all the rules of what dominant
inheritance looks like, what recessive inheritance looks like. So,
if you see a trait that happens in a
grandparent, a parent and a child, then that's much
more likely to be a dominant trait. If you
see a condition where multiple brothers and sisters are
[INAUDIBLE]
and by chance maybe their parents are related to each other. And no one
else in the family has the trait,
then that's more likely or suggestive something
recessive. And if you see only boys affected through moms, that could be more
X-linked. So the pedigree really does help
us try to figure out modes of inheritance.
>> That's really cool.
>> Yeah.
>> what about, I'm super curious, because in, in
our class, we, we actually learn about sort of the
possibility of recessive and dominant in, in
an autosomal context and in excellent context. We
also briefly go over a maternal inheritance, which
would be any conditions that affect mitochondria presumably.
>> Yes, yes.
>> Are there any conditions or traits that you ever
have to deal with that fit that model at all?
>> So, I'm very fortunate that I, I don't interact, or I
don't have to deal so much
with maternal inheritance like mitochondrial inheritance,
because it can be. That's that's still a very
tricky type of inheritance, up a long with imprinting effects.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So there's some complicated modes of inheritance, that, I mean you could
see in a prenatal pedigree, but would be hard to be born out unless
someone had a name of a known mitochondrial condition. but my colleagues in
pediatrics, certainly are looking at children where
they might be something mitochondrial going on.
it gives a specific phenotype or picture,
where children have certain metabolic lab results, they
have learning delays or physical problems. so often
times they are telling families, there's a diagnosis
of something mitochondrial and trying to explain
inheritance patterns. Which, that is, that is really
tough, because there's a much higher recurrence risk
in that then the traditional modes of inheritance.
>> Have
you ever had to look at a trait, or
I don't know, I'm just curious, have you ever looked
where there, no one knows what the inheritance pattern
is? Like have you ever discovered a new inheritance pattern?
>>
[LAUGH]
>> Like does that happen as a genetic counselor? Are
you ever looking at traits that no one's ever described before?
>> So that's kind of two separate questions.
So that, looking at a pedigree, sometimes we
don't know the inheritance. Like it doesn't fit
a traditional dominant, or it doesn't fit a traditional
recessive. So that's kind of the fun part
of our job, where it's a rare occurrence of
something happening. So it's not, I don't think
we've discovered a new inheritance, but we've discovered new
instances of a rare, rare instances of things that
can happen with traditional inheritance patterns. So that's, that's one
way. Like something happens on top of something else
and that's what gives that pattern. and then we can
also be fooled when people are related to each
other. because then that throws things, because it could be
a dominant trait. But if there's relatives that are, are
related to each other, it could be recessive as well.
>> Mm-hm.
>> and
then your other question just about. I mean, we certainly
have conditions that nobody's described before. And we see it
in prenatal, but we see it more in pediatrics, where
a child comes to us with a unique set of symptoms
and that's not been described. And so that, that's a
cool part of a pediatric genetics counselor's or doctor's job
is they might actually identify a new syndrome. So, I
haven't personally been part of that, but my colleagues actually have.
And we know physicians who have discovered new
conditions and have had them named after them.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah.
>> That's crazy. That's pretty cool. I also wanted to know, I, you know, when
I learned genetics the first time, and, as you just said a second ago, it,
it happens. And you have to look
for it, you're looking for maybe recessive traits,
and, you see a, unaffected parents and
affected children, and you're looking for, maybe, close
relation.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, for new beginnings, new, new,
new students to a class of genetics are like,
has that really happened. If people find out
that they actually had children can, can we speak
to that all. How, how often do you
people find out either, whether they knew or didn't
know that they, they you know, didn't have children
with somebody of a close relation. What's that like?
>> So, I would say that the, what we
call consanguinity when people are related to each other.
Often, in my experience, it's not an unknown thing.
I mean there a certain cultures in other countries where
it's actually preferred that people marry within the family.
and so, it's actually a known thing up front that
they have to marry within the family to keep
funding, or money, or status in the family. I have
had one instance when I was talking to a
patient on the phone and drawing her pedigree, that she
did not know she had married either a
first or se, her, her husband was her first
or second cousin. And that she found out
when they were invited to the same family wedding.
[LAUGH]
So, I mean, so, I think it doesn't happen in, for, at
least for me, it hasn't happened that often where people don't know
they're related to each other. Often times they're coming to us because
they already know that somehow and they're worried about the risks from that.
>> Sure. because you hear, we learn about it in textbooks,
but, I'm like, what, what context does that really happen in?
>> Or I guess not even relatedness but coming from
the same community. So, for example, just people of Ashkenazi Jewish
descents, and I, and I would say hopefully it's
not disrespectful for anyone from that community. But I
think there are a lot of communities, whether they're
religious or cultural that tend to marry from that community.
>> Sure.
>> And it's just, I think they call it a Founder Effect. Somebody, an
ancestor in that, from that gener, culture happened to carry a bad recessive or
serious recessive gene like Tay-Sachs disease. And he happened to have a lot of
children and those children happy, happened to
marry each other. And then that condition
really increased in incidents. And so that's happened,
that's been known to happen in certain part pockets.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Of population, even if they're not related to each other. If they're a
close community. So so it's fortunate or
unfortunate. And, and the Jewish population in general
I feel like they, they are aware of those increased risks. So many people are
screened to see if they carry some of these genes, even before they get married.
>> I see. Well, let's, let's close out here.
I'm curious, let's maybe think broad aspect again, broad
perspective. What what do you think other people think
about genetics and genetic counseling? What do you, what, what
do you think the general viewpoint is? And, and
do you think that's good or bad, and should
we try to change that or influence it in a certain way or is it fine on its own?
>> So, I, I, I might,
I'm al, I'm very interested in what, in what
the public opinion is of genetic counseling. And I
feel like we here in the Bay Area are
in a very specific bubble, where we're very fortunate,
we're in a very liberal area. where genetic testing
is available, pregnancy termination is available. And so, I
feel like the, the opinion of genetic counselors here
in this area is fairly favorable. That people definitely if
they have met with a genetic counselor, have definitely found it
helpful and useful. I actually don't think in general nationwide. I still
think it's a fairly small profession. And my sense is that,
I mean, we're doing more to promote the profession, but I think
there's still a lot of people who don't know what genetic
counselors do and where they fit into things. A lot of patients
even here, especially if they come from other countries, will hear
the counseling part of genetic and think that it's a therapy session.
so there's still a lot of misconceptions about what
the term means. I don't think it's viewed negatively.
I think it's just, it's still not very well
known like other allied health professionals, professions like nurses,
or social workers, or dentists. So, there's it's encouraging
that there are more and more of us. And
with the media being more available on the internet,
hopefully we'll be promoting our profession better. and just
spreading the word of the benefits of genetic counseling.
>> Great. If you, if, if there's somebody watching right now and is really
interested and wants to learn more about
being a genetic counselor, what would you,
do you have any particular good resource you would tell them to go visit?
Or do you have any special message you would tell them about genetic counseling?
>> So, yeah. I would, I would highly recommend that their profession if
anyone's thinking about genetic counseling. it's
a very good combination of medicine and
health care, and interacting with patients. So we call
that a clinical kind of drive, if you like patients.
And if you like a specific field of genetics, because
that's pretty much what we're talking about. So if you
don't like genetics, I wouldn't recommend this profession. But if
you want to work with people, but still be in tune
with the science, it's a really good profession. and we
do have a national society. So there's a website nsgc.org,
that has all the information about the training programs, the
background requirements. we've done professional
status surveys to talk about salary,
job satisfaction. genetic conselors tend to be more on the side
of female. I think it's actually up to 95% are female.
>> Holy cow.
>>
[LAUGH].
So the male genetic counselors are very well known
in the field because there aren't that many of them
[LAUGH].
Especially here in California. so, because of that, there's good
and bad for that. there are a lot of counselors
who work part time, and we don't take call like
physicians or nurses. And so, for those again who want
to go into medicine but don't want the extra stress
of those kinds of things, it's a really nice profession.
a lot of, lots of counselors work part time. again,
because we're seeing patients and they can be scheduled appointments.
the salaries I think, especially with our certification and licensure, hopefully
are starting to increase. And there's certainly a lot of job opportunity.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, I would highly recommend checking out the websites,
and talking to a genetic counselor if you can. Even shadowing
a counselor and doing some volunteer work in healthcare. Just to
make sure that's the area that they like to be in.